good morning nation my name is Evan
Carmichael by one word and believe as I
believe that entrepreneurs will solve
all of the world's major problems should
I help you on your journey today's
message is think outside the box over to
you in Cottonwood every gym I went here
was always they had a set way every gym
had a set way of doing things don't do
it this way do it that way so that was
just a normal thing that I taught I
thought just people just have their own
that way and you must do it that way
you must stand this way you must kick
this way you must punch this way but
with John when I went to John I met my
coach John cabinet astray by him it
wasn't like that he had a more open mind
and he encouraged different movements
and I never experienced that before I've
never heard a coach say that to me
before
and I stuck my head in I thought to
myself no this guy is thinking outside
the box you know I mean he has a vision
that everything works on a knee he
encourages every movement because
ultimately there is a time and a place
for every single move so I just had I
just knew one when I met John and I when
he spoke it made complete sense to me
and that was the I stood with him and he
stuck with me and the rest is history
so he just way I know of that because of
the box a lot of things you have to be
creative genius you have to be artistic
you have to think a certain way to think
outside the box you don't anybody can
think outside the box for me the easiest
way to do it it just takes something
from another industries that you also
love and bring it to your market this is
where if you combine the genes to the
end if you embrace the things that makes
you you that's where you want
pretty eloquent because you have all
sorts of different interests if you
never again really take one thing then
you're going to focus on this is
noticing an interview one you're going
to feel left out because there's all
these other interests that you have and
to you guys it's tough because the
people who love that thing more than you
are going to go freshen where you can
combine all these things that is the one
you break everything that is loved by
the way that mixed up into pot people
can't replicate you your unique yummy
voice every unique approach to catch a
copy do the best that ever going to be
is a junior version of you and so you
think outside the box but taking all the
different interests and thinking
something that's working something out
and bring it to the thing that you're
joining and people now suddenly to say
that you are previous that you're so
great at thinking outside the box all
you're really doing is just pulling it
in the street and this has worked over
over over over and over again I was at
Starbucks I love how it shows is not
from the wall in my office she got the
idea for Starbucks when he went on a
trip to the land you went to Italy and
saw that the coffee shops with a center
of life in Italy and has a productive
that was the third halt it has their
office they had their moment he has the
coffee shop where people you hang out in
meeting place and he looked at North
America we saw the Dunkin Donuts of the
world where you just come in and out
grab a coffee there's more utilities and
he wanted to create that same virtual
lives in North America work in Italy for
decades let's just bring it in North
America and go you know one of the
biggest brains in the world was born not
because how is this Assyria creative
genius but because he's borrowed from
other industries and brought his own you
look at the teaching there's a couple
things that I brought here from other
industries that have helped my channel
grow
I have the salsa business I was
assaulted DJ part of me James is taking
lots of different songs and mixing them
up in a way that makes sense for a dance
party I think that for a lot of my top
tens and for a lot of the reasons that I
do I pull together different clips that
I feel work well together we make it
into an experience
enjoy nobody else is doing that is
definitely in a business context an
entrepreneurship contact Huntington when
it's helped me when I also first seats
you buy the business I'm an entrepreneur
the idea that I want to respond
everybody moving to comment and I've
hired people on my team and may need to
hire somebody else if you guys are
commenting so quickly
that we're following you night a little
bit right I want everybody to have to
respond I'm a comment but somebody is in
to comment I want to respond to them I
think it's important things as part of
is if somebody calls your store or
walked into your front door you're going
to talk to them you're going to thank
them you can acknowledge them and at the
beginning if allows YouTube channel
creators will respond to every comment
is every time every comment and it's
easy to just one comment a day or ten
comments it's not that hard to respond
to every comment but when you're getting
two three four hundred comments a day
let's see if you can keep up and still
they can and so they just drop it where
my approach is no it'll just drop it a
sell for you just bring on people to
help you you don't have to do everything
in your business just like if the real
business world keeps locked my books
over when you enjoy the real business
world you start out doing everything
yourself and the dependent of team to
help you and you move up and you start
focusing on the things that you're good
into the physical good and so taking
that approach you bring it to my youtube
channel are still both creators of life
eyes are not responding this is most of
the comments right these may respond to
a couple and religiously business where
I was unlovable be nation I love the two
years because important you guys are
connecting and getting along and there's
a vibrant discussion and so I want to
make sure this recognition is options
are a hire people to help me and so I
talked to the guys at YouTube with my
account manager wow that's such an
outside-the-box idea it's not wanted by
the bottom not by creative it's just
taking something I work for business and
bringing it easy to write and so you
don't need to be in seeing the creative
person you don't
be the wire characters always thinking
outside the box we to do is just take
other things that your passions on who
love baseball or you love Celine Dion
we love beavers or you love grocery
stores or you love Harlem whatever it is
you're very interest love the Smurfs you
know whatever it is find out something
that works there in that community in
that business model and just bring it to
what you're currently doing and if it's
different
let me just stand out people will
suddenly tell you as the next creative
genius and outside the box
so the question setting is I'm curious
what is one of the more outside the box
I see is you pass and you pull from a
different industry and applies your
business really curious to find out
doing downtown fellows I also want to
give a quick trade to Gary Wilson gear
and thank you so much your victim top of
mind folks you want work I really
appreciate support Gary's that I hope
you enjoyed the week so thank you guys
so much for watching I believe would you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one where it is much loved
and as you get far more day for another
shot of espresso I work
[Music]
I'm thinking it's so superior and why
nowadays so popular and my logic so
while until it clashes with the
mentality which is down here and I'm
both there I'm even for her I can seem
wealthy father knew and you looking at
missus how do you don't do it honey
please down layered and you own a job
making sixty seventy pounds a week all
over this day I never I never been out
of the country not known in his own
neighborhood Sally don't do it but I'm
in such a high level until I don't think
with you I'm not like you
I know it's a you a means on your person
but you're not but you know why they say
that I'm a so the bet on simple reason
so they appear and they aware it looks
looks dangerous to them that's not
really the danger to me don't let
expertise
silence you work to find new solutions
to old problems think outside the
parameters that restrict other people's
thoughts just because you're a novice on
the job just because you haven't faced
the same challenges just because you
haven't climbed the same cliffs doesn't
mean that you can't contribute to
solutions in very significant ways when
you're chided for your naivete and you
will be rely on your critics that are
amateur-built the art experts built the
Titanic man statistic said if I did that
and I stopped going to school and that's
all idea was hanging the hood that I
wasn't going to be here today
mmm-hmm so that's why I still hang with
the same people that I was with back in
the hood and I changed my mentality I
don't think the same way I was when I
was there open my mind up I thought
broader I thought outside of my horizons
like you got to think outside the box
mmm-hmm because that's the only way
you're gonna get out when you trapped in
the shop you really mentally trapped in
the trap and it's me be like man I want
to make sure my people just know that
that's just not the end of your life
like if somebody tell you these
statistics is not true you're gonna
fight statistics and go to the next
level night so chick sir said I wouldn't
even be here talking to you right
mmm-hmm if I were to listen to them and
tell them how my life would have been
they say one out of ten people they're
gonna be like this one nine out of ten
black males if they do this live this
way they're gonna do this you know I'm
saying there's no way around it they
gonna tell you is nowhere around so if
you in the hood right now you're
standing on a block every day then
police is run by the old lady that's
looking at you that's calling the police
on you yeah the people who ran by just
looking at you like laying nests in your
pants saggin I think you ain't gonna
never be nothing they think you're gonna
be like that for the rest of your life
like who is the person to tell you that
you're gonna be standing on this block
all your life opposed to be a point in
your life where you own the beer for you
get yourself a year to you from here it
don't do no good for you to be here all
your life and you're spending majority
of your life
22 hours I showed a trying to prove you
the harder than the hood you come from
the Jews boiling is you when you came
home from the hospital you went to the
hood you know I'm saying so you don't
live your whole life this way for all
your life you deserve to live in a
different neighborhood better yourself
for 3-4 years out of your whole life
when you've been living this way
probably some dudes been living that way
for 20 years 23 years been in the hood
since they came home from from the house
field and they still trying to prove to
the hood our heart day is in the end I'm
not making it because they didn't prove
today self you gotta prove to yourself
that you want more than what is hot off